uh all right great so it's our great
honor to have polling glow speaking
about statistical
uh estimation rates
and uh in order to not delay the talk
any further all pulling take it away
all right um thanks very much so um
thank you to the organizers for
inviting me to give this presentation um
i really wish i could be there in person
but i'm glad that i have the opportunity
to present
virtually
so
i decided that since this is a tutorial
talk
or boot camp talk rather i would give
the talk via writing on an ipad
it's a bit difficult because i don't
actually have any expressions to go off
of to know whether i'm going too fast or
too slow
but i'll try to go at a reasonable
reasonable pace and please do feel free
to stop me if you have questions about
anything
so the topic is lower bounds on
statistical estimation rates under
various constraints and we are going to
be covering four different topics so the
first one is just the basics
of
information theoretic
information theoretic bounds
and then the second one is
lower bounds under the constraint of
robustness
then the third topic will be lower
bounds under the constraint of
differential privacy
and then the fourth one will be
constraints of computation
and roughly speaking
we'll have one lecture for each although
differential privacy will probably be
slightly longer and computation will be
slightly shorter
and that's because i think many of the
other bootcamp speakers are talking
about computation
and some
some constraints which are not covered
are communication constraints which are
also studied
and other
constraints like memory or storage
constraints
um so we will focus here on lower bounds
so we will focus on establishing
lower bounds
and
only mention
algorithms
that achieve
the same upper balance
okay so as you'll see um the methods
that we use for proving lower bounds
will all be information theoretic we
want to know what's the best performance
we can hope for from any estimator
um we'll also want to know uh in
practice whether or not we can achieve
these uh bounds but oftentimes the
proofs for proving upper bounds are
quite different from the proofs for
proving lower bounds so i'll just tell
you in each of these cases what the
algorithms would be without proving
anything okay so let's dig into topic
one so topic one is basic lower bound
techniques
okay
um so what we want to do well here's a
reference so i'll give you a reference
for each one of the lectures
um
we'll go off of material in the textbook
by wainwright
high dimensional statistics
from 2019.
oh another thing i wanted to say is that
i will be doing quite a few computations
and derivations and proofs
and the reason is that i sort of want to
make the process of proving lower bounds
a little bit less mysterious so i would
like to include details so you can kind
of see how these things work
but i won't have time to go through all
the details so i'll skip some small
technical statements that are plausibly
true and you can look up or try to prove
it by yourself later
so we want to characterize
the minimax risk
which is defined by enthemum over
estimators theta
supremum over
distributions in some
set script p
expectation where the data comes from p
of some loss function applied to an
estimator which is
applied to the data
and some parameter of the
unknown distribution
and here
p
is a class
of data generating distributions
and the expectation
is taken
with respect to a particular
distribution
p in script p
and the parameter of interest
is some functional theta of p
there's a particular case that we will
focus on which is when we have a
parametric family
so a special case and i think this will
be the case for all of the examples that
we cover in all of our lectures
so script p
is a parametric family
so p theta and we're going to say p
theta to the n because we're going to
assume we have iid observations
all right so p theta p is a parametric
family
do you hear us if we ask a question just
like this
sorry go ahead what's your question yeah
this is uh
i just uh have it's a little small when
it comes out on the on this uh portrait
okay would you be able to switch to
landscape by a chance
um i can try that and see what happens
um
let's see
let's see that i don't use ipads very
often
um
yeah great all right but now i might
have to write giant too okay so the
special case is where um script p is a
parametric family
um
and we have id observations so x is iid
from p sub theta
then the min and max risk
can be also be written as in them over
theta hat
supremum over parameters theta and
capital theta
expectation where x is the data um
is a data set of iid points which we're
going to denote by x distributed as p
theta to the n the product distribution
and now it's the loss between theta hat
applied to the data and the true
parameter data okay so i think in all
the examples that we're going to go
through we'll be looking at a parametric
family but in the first lecture at least
we're going to derive these results in
more generality
so
we will suppose throughout
that l has a special form so the loss
function that we're using is of the form
fee composed with rho
where
phi is an increasing function
and rho is a semi-metric
which means that it has
three properties so it satisfies the
triangle inequality
it satisfies symmetry so rho of
u v is equal to rho of v u
and also
rho of v v is equal to zero
okay um and
uh the reason why we we do this in more
generality is that for instance
as an example we might want
rho is equal to some sort of a norm
which satisfies the triangle inequality
and then phi
is equal to the square because for
instance maybe we want to measure these
risks in terms of the squared l2 norm
and
we will need to apply a triangle
inequality but we can't do it directly
on l
okay so
um the main tool that we're going to
focus on is finals inequality
so in this part i'll both remind you
what foundation equality is and give you
the general technique for improving
lower bounds
um so the idea
is to transform
the estimation problem
into a decoding problem
and the goal
is to
infer the correct message
from a discrete set of messages
corresponding to a collection of
distributions
to uh well let's say it to a subset
of
the whole class of distributions
and the estimation problem
is at least as hard as the decoding
problem
if the distributions are well separated
so this is all a little bit abstract so
let me tell you precisely what i mean
okay so consider a set
p1 p2
pm
which is a subset of script p
such that now here's the well separated
part we need rho of theta of
pi theta of p j to be greater than or
equal to two delta
delta for all i not equal to j so
remember the row um semi-metric operates
on the data space
um now
let
psi of x
a particular
well i guess it's not exactly an
estimator but it gives you an index so
let's psi of x
be the decision rule
psi of x
equals
r min
over
all indices j
of rho of
theta of
p j
theta hat of x okay so what this means
is that we have these um well separated
distributions at least in the theta
space so you can think about theta of p1
theta of p2 etc
then theta hat of x lands somewhere
let's say it lands here
okay that's the particular output of an
algorithm um and then what this uh
what psi does is it maps it to the
closest one so in this case
it gets mapped there and psi would just
be the index one
and
we'll say
where ties are broken arbitrarily
okay um so now we write the following
so then
expectation where x comes from p i
of uh i guess it's p i to the n oh sorry
no it's not p is the end so this is the
the general situation where p i is a
distribution in let's say the whole
product space
we have l of theta hat of x
and theta of v i
and this is going to be greater than or
equal to
phi of
delta times probability so here we're
applying markov's inequality probability
that l of theta hat of x
theta of p i is bigger than or equal to
v of delta
and this is equal to
v of delta times now we use the fact
that um that l is equal to
phi composed with rho and phi is an
increasing function so we just get rid
of the phi x is derivative as t i
rho of theta hat of x
theta of p i greater than or equal to
delta
um and now this actually is greater than
or equal to
v of delta
times the error probability probability
that when x is distributed as p i
psi of x is not equal to i okay so why
is this last statement true
well if you think about it
let's say star
star comes from
the containment
that the event that
rho of theta hat of x
theta of p i
is less than delta
is contained in
psi of x
is equal to i
okay so um so if this event is true then
certainly the probability that
the right hand side is not true is less
than or equal to the probability that
the left-hand side is not true that's
where we're getting this and then why is
this containment true
well if
if phi
of x
is uh is closer than delta to um the
actual distribution then we'll get
mapped to the um to the correct thing
and this is because we we have assumed
that um that all of the distributions
are two delta separated right
um
okay
good so um now what do we do with this
well our um
our risk had to do with a supremum over
all distributions p of this sort of loss
so of course we can bound this lower
bound to supremum by
an average of several distributions
so now we say that
supremum over p in script p of
expectation x distributed as p
of l of
of theta hat of x
theta of p
is going to be bigger than or equal to
1 over m
sum i goes from 1 to m
expectation under x distributed as p i
of l of theta hat of x
theta of p i
all right and now we have um well this
this statement up here gives us a lower
bound that we can just plug in
so this is bigger than or equal to
b of delta over m
times the sum
i goes from 1 to m
of probability x distributed as p i
psi of x is not equal to i
okay so we have this lower bound on the
risk
and now here's where we use finals
inequality from information theory so
recall
nano's inequality
and that says that
for any
estimator
y hat of y
such that
y to x to
y hat forms a markov chain
we have
probability y hat is not equal to y
is lower bounded by
h of y given x minus 1
over
log base 2 of script y
where y is the range
of y
okay so this is like the probability of
error if you will of any estimator so
here you can think about trying to
estimate what y is you get an output y
hat and this lower bounds the
probability of error of any estimator
okay so um we're going to apply this
fondos inequality to get a handle on
these guys
so now
y
be distributed
uniformly
on the index set 1 up to m
and let x be distributed
according
to p sub y
um remember p sub i are all the um all
the distributions in this collection
that we
that we're considering
so then applying
the lemma
with y hat equals psi of x
and then gives
one over m
sum
i goes from one to m
uh probability x distributed as p i
psi of x not equal to i so
this is the quantity that we care about
from
up here
and this is going to be equal oops
my eraser
so this is equal to the probability that
y hat
is not equal to y
and by finals inequality this is bigger
than or equal to
h of y given x
minus 1 over log base 2 of m since our
head size m
and we can rewrite this as
log base 2 of m
minus the mutual information between x
and y minus 1
over log 2 of m
and why is this true well this is just
because of the conditional entropy
[Music]
since
i of
xy iyx
is equal to h of y minus h of y given x
and
h of y is equal to log 2 sub m
since y is uniform
okay so
all together our main result
is that in femum over theta hat
supremum over p in script p expectation
x distributed as p
l of theta hat x
theta of p
is going to be bigger than or equal to
so actually there was a
there was an extra oh screen sharing
ended
let's fix this
okay so um where were we
yeah i guess i was scrolling up to say
that there was an extra factor of um
of v of delta
um and then whatever we get from
um let me just scroll back up so
so what we wanted was we have just lower
bounded this stuff so we have an extra
factor of
v of delta
and putting it all together we have
one
minus
i of y x plus 1 over
log base 2 of m
okay so this is the lower bound that
comes from finals inequality
and now so the main point is that to
apply this
the inequality in practice
we need to
let's say a construct
an appropriate set
appropriate two delta
separated set
in the row metric
and b
[Music]
bound
the quantity i of y x so i'll say um
that at least in most of the
applications
what you do is you try to
you try to lower bound um this whole
quantity here by one half so that the
rate that falls out is
of the order of um v of delta so if you
want to lower bound this stuff by one
half then that means that you want to
upper bound i of y x okay
so let's now talk
very briefly about how you usually upper
bound i of y x so
the next subtopic
is bounds on mutual information
right um and
so what you do is
um well for now so let's write
p bar to be equal to the mixture
distribution one over m sum j goes from
one to m
p j so let this be the mixture
distribution
um
then we can check that
i of y x
is equal to one over m
some
i goes from one to m of the kl
divergence between
p i and p bar
and
this it turns out is upper bounded by
one over m some i goes from one to m
one over m some goes some
j goes from one to m
of the kl divergence between pi and pj
and this last inequality comes from the
convexity
of the kl divergence
in the second argument
okay so
therefore
to upper bound
i of
y x
it suffices
to
[Music]
obtain
bounds on pairwise
kl divergences
now of course this bound could be loose
and there are definitely cases in which
this is not what you want to do but then
there are also cases when it's easy to
construct the set and also
and verify that the parameters are two
delta separated and also verify that
these the kl divergences are paralyzed
bounded by something
okay
and this method is known as the local
packing approach
okay so to make things a little bit less
abstract now we're going to run through
a few examples
um
we're going to run through three
examples and
these examples in addition
in addition to um
to helping you understand how you would
use these results actually these are
examples that we're going to be
returning to when we add on different
constraints
later on
so the three examples are normal mean
estimation
normal covariance estimation
and high dimensional regression
okay
and as i said i will go through
some of some of the parts in more detail
than others
so let's first talk about
normal mean estimation
okay so what we have is this is a
parametric problem we have x i which are
coming iid from
a distribution
normal theta sigma squared
i sub p so p dimensional normal
distribution
and the goal
is to estimate
theta
data which is living in rp okay
so we will show using
this method
that in human over theta hat
to premium over theta in rp
expectation where we have iid data
coming from p theta
of theta hat minus theta two norm
squared
is
of the order lower bounded by um sigma
squared p over n
okay and as i said i'm not going to talk
about um
upper bounds but a matching upper bound
can be obtained just using the empirical
mean
okay so another way of thinking about
this is you know maybe you have an
estimation problem you have an estimator
that you think should um be a good one
you get an upper bound perhaps by um by
deriving some concentration inequalities
and you want to know whether or not
there's some estimator that could do
better
and what this is saying is that in fact
there isn't any estimator that could do
better
okay so how do we how do we achieve the
lower bound
so we will use fano
rano's method
with rho equal to the l2 norm and
phi of t equal to t squared okay so
that's how we get the squared l2 norm
for our loss now
[Music]
that script v
be
a one-half packing
of the unit
l2 ball so we'll use this notation again
later so let's call it b2 of one
and the l2 norm
so what do i mean by one half packing um
well this is the language of metric
entropy so this means that i have my
ball
of radius 1 and l2 norm and i want to
place
points in it so that pairwise distances
between any two of them is at least one
half
okay
um
so
now by results by standard results
um such
a set
of cardinality
script v bigger than two to the p exists
okay
um so now
now we need to well this is just um a
packing of the of the unit ball um of
course our our whole parameter space is
all of our p so we can do different
things with this what we're going to do
is rescale this packing to obtain
to obtain uh the parameters theta that
pack our space
uh the other thing is of course we want
it to be two delta separated here it's
one half separated so we need to get the
delta in there somewhere
okay so
um now for each
v in script v
we define
theta sub v equal four delta v
where delta will be determined later
okay so here's where we're going to get
our two delta separated part and
actually this will hold for any delta
but then the whole game is to set delta
later and a bound will fall out okay so
now let's check that this is two delta
separated
so
for
v not equal to v prime
we can verify so we're looking at
um these
parameters and we want these parameters
to be at least 2 delta apart so remember
that our
our metric was the l2 metric so now
we're looking at separation in terms of
l2 norm and this is exactly equal to 4
delta times v minus v prime
and
this is then going to be at least four
delta times one half since this is going
to happen
okay good so we we scaled everything
correctly um and we have two delta
separation and now the other thing that
we need to do is um is we need to get an
upper bound on the kl divergence between
pairs
so we look at
pv
and pb prime right because by finals
inequality we wanted an upper bound on
pairs
um and you can calculate this
so remember what is pv well p is a
gaussian distribution right it's a
gaussian distribution up here with mean
whatever we get from v and variance
sigma squared times the identity
now
the the parameter is 4 delta times v so
really we have a kl divergence between
between two normal distributions where
the means are 4 delta v and 4 delta v
prime and the covariance matrices of
both are sigma squared times i
so you can check that this is equal to
16 delta squared
over 2 sigma squared times v minus v
prime to an arm squared less than or
equal to 32.
squared over
delta squared
okay
um
and
right
okay so um
oh yeah one thing i wanted to note was
that um
[Music]
we have this formula
for the kl divergence between two normal
distributions
mu one sigma one
and
mu 2 sigma 2. so i'm just writing this
out
just to remind you we'll use this
this expression for several different kl
divergence problems in these tutorials
this is the log of the determinant of
sigma 2
over sigma 1 minus p
plus trace of
sigma 2 inverse
sigma 1 plus
mu 1 minus mu 2 transpose
sigma 2 inverse times mu 1 minus mu 2.
okay so to get
this equality here we're really just
plugging it into this more general
formula
okay so what's the point
um well one thing to notice is that
actually um well
so therefore um i of
y x is bounded by 32
um
well i should say i i of y x is actually
bounded by
dkl of
pvn
pv and prime okay so if we go back um
maybe this is maybe already realized
this but we go back to our bound on the
mutual information right we want our
mutual we said that if the pairwise
scale divergences are bounded by
something mutual information is bounded
by that thing but now we need to
remember that in this more abstract um
statement of well in in our derivation
of bondo's inequality
we were dealing with these p i's as
being the n fold product distributions
and down here um
when i've computed this kl divergence
this is just as if we had one sample
from a gaussian distribution so really
we need to be looking at the n fold
product distributions well we know that
the kl divergence tense arises so this
is n times
dkl of pv
pv prime so our bound tells us that this
is bounded by 32 and delta squared over
sigma squared
okay so
now we have all the ingredients we need
um so then thanos inequality
implies
the lower bound
of delta squared so um
in fano's inequality we have phi of
delta remember that phi is the squared
function
um and then one minus the kl divergence
upper bound 32 and delta squared over
sigma squared and there was a plus one
and then
we divide by the log of
m which is going to be
equal to p
okay so let me just scroll up again to
remind you um well fano is bound
um we have a log base 2 of m m is the
size of the cardinality of the set and i
said that
there exists a packing which has
size at least 2 to the m
i'm sorry 2 to the p so log base 2 of
that is just p
okay so now what do we do with this um
well as i said the game is to say well
how should i choose
delta
squared so that this is lower bounded by
one half all right
so
[Music]
so if you want to
to set
the second quantity equal to one-half
then you can
manipulate things and you'll see that
what you should do is you should take
delta squared
to be on the order of
sigma squared p over n
okay so you just repeat that to make
this guy order of one half you can
rearrange things so delta squared should
be this order
um and then that says that we can ignore
the second term and our rate is really
just delta squared so this implies that
the minimax risk
is
omega of delta squared p over n which is
what i claimed up above
all right
so that's example one
um
and now let me do example two
so and you'll see that there's
there's some similarities here um but
let's just go right ahead and do it
so this is example two which is
covariance matrix estimation
so you'll see that here constructing the
packing set is a little bit different
so now the problem is that we suppose
that we have x i
which is distributed iid as
normal
zero sigma and the goal is to estimate
the covariance matrix
sigma r to the p by p
from the parameter space
we're going to define
theta to be equal to
all matrices sigma which are psd so
let's write it like this and also the
spectral norm is bounded by
lambda so here i mean
this is the psd cone
and this here is the spectral norm
um
and we will show
bound
enthemum over
estimators sigma hat
supremum over estimated sigma hat in our
space theta
expectation x distributed as p sigma and
again we have an n fold
set of samples
sigma hat minus sigma 2 norm squared
is equal to omega of lambda squared p
over n
okay so lambda remember is our bound of
the on the spectral norm over the class
um
and
an upper bound so a matching upper bound
can be obtained using the sample
covariance matrix
again using concentration inequalities
okay
so how are we going to establish this
lower bound well of course we'll use
fano's inequality so
we'll apply fano's inequality
with
rho is equal to the spectral norm of
matrices and v of t is equal to t
squared so again we have squared
spectral norm so we're going to to do it
like this
now we need to define the set that we're
going to use so
um so here i'm going to skip a bunch of
details and just give you the main ideas
of the construction
so for r greater than 0
define the set
k sub r a k of r
is equal to
lambda over 2
um i plus
bf let me just write out the expression
it'll tell you what these notations mean
intersect b2 of one half
intersect sp
so this is um
bf is the frobenius norm ball
and then b2 is of course the spectral
normal ball around zero
okay and this sum here is the minkowski
sum
which i guess just means that what we're
doing is we're taking an element which
is
which has frobenius norm bounded by root
two r spectral norm bounded by one half
we add an i to it um
and and we need to make sure that this
is pst rescale it by lambda over two so
um the one thing i want to note is that
in fact k of r is a subset of
theta so we're trying to find a subset
of our parameter space so we better
actually have a subset of it remember
that theta had every um every matrix
inside of it was supposed to be with
spectral norm bounded by lambda so this
better be the case here
and you can check that
well um you're taking a matrix you're
taking i you're taking a matrix with
spectral norm bounded by one half so
what you get is something the spectral
norm bounded by three quarters um
sorry by three halves by the triangle
inequality and all together we have
three times lambda over four
so
since um
[Music]
central norm of any uh sigma in the set
is bounded by land over two times
three halves equals three lambda over
four is less than lambda
for sigma in case k of r
okay
and
um so we will take and of course this
comes out of the technical arguments
later but i'll just tell you what works
so we'll take r equals
1 over n times p
p plus one over two
okay
so
one can show that
for sigma one and sigma two
and k of r
write that again in k of r
we have
d k l of
e sigma 1 oops screen sharing just
stopped again um
oh no i think i hit something
okay
yeah there we go
[Music]
okay we're back so um one can show that
for sigma 1 sigma 2 and kr we have
pairwise kl divergences bounded
so this guy is
less than or equal to
16r
and i guess this comes from the fact
that um
it's one of these two things that uh
that the frobenius norm and the l2 norm
of the matrices are bounded
appropriately um so this gives us and
i'm not going to prove this but this
gives us the upper bound and parallel
pairwise kl divergences
so
next
we show the existence
of a
large set
p1 up to pm
which is a subset of k of r
which is 2 sub 2 delta separated
in
spectral norm
using a metric entropy
slash volumetric argument
okay so maybe one thing to note is that
um what i've set up here is that
actually any two um if i choose any two
parameters in this set then the pair by
cl differences are bounded so in the
previous construction i first found a
two delta separated set and then i said
that for these two dozen separated guys
the pairwise cable divergences were
bounded this is saying that for any
points that i choose the pairwise kl
divergences are bounded therefore i can
just focus on unfinding a separated set
okay um and here again i'm not going to
say too many details
so
um
so here's a fact or here are a few facts
so the two delta packing number
is
lower bounded by the
two delta covering number
and just to say a word about this well
the two delta packing number um is the
yeah so this is the max
number of two delta points we can pack
in
meaning that all all pairs are two delta
separated the two delta covering number
is the minimum
number of points
so that
um two delta balls
around the points
cover the set
okay so it's a standard it's a standard
result that the two dollar packing
number is lower bounded by two delta
covering number um and importantly
though this is
in turn
lower bounded
by the vault by the volume ratio so
volume of k of r
divided by
the volume of this set
which is
b2 of
2 delta
intersect st
okay so essentially
this denominator here is just asking me
well what is the volume of you know if i
want to make sure that
so okay so this is relating the two
delta covering number to the volumes so
two delta covering um tells me how many
points are covered by a ball of radius
two delta right so what i'm doing down
here is i'm looking at the ball of a
radius two delta in the in the two norm
because i'm calculating everything in
the two norm i intersect with the um
with the psd matrices because that's
really all i care about and i take the
total volume and i divide it by this
volume
okay
um and then through a somewhat technical
argument so using
some results
in convex geometry
one can show
that the latter quantity
is lower bounded
[Music]
by
some constant times lambda
over delta
square root of p over n to the power p
times p plus 1 over 2 okay so i'm
skipping the details because there are
quite a lot of them
so
if we accept all of this what have we
seen well we've seen that we have a
bound on the total number of points in
this set so this is going to be our
capital m and we have a bound on the kl
divergences which gives us a bound on i
and now we can just put it all together
and plug it into finals inequality
so
plugging
into whanau's inequality
gives a lower bound um
of the order
um
let's say
constant so this is just so i can be a
little bit loose well there was the fee
of delta apart right and phi here is the
squared uh function so i have a delta
squared i have one minus um i need to
write down what i saw from the
upper bound on kl divergences
so this is the 16 r um
here r is equal to this quantity so
roughly p squared over n um i also have
to remember to multiply everything by n
since it's an n full product
so i have
n times
16 p squared over n
and then there's a 1 but i'm going to
it's not really important
and then i take the log of the number of
guys
in my
in my set so that's of the order of p
squared
log of c delta
over c lambda over delta square root of
p over n and maybe just to disambiguate
let's make that a c prime okay so the
game even though this looks kind of ugly
uh the the game of course is to lower
bound on this quantity here by one half
so we can
try to see well
the ends cancel out right and actually
the the p squared roughly cancel out if
i
if i ignore the one
and the p squared's cancel out so really
i should just be making um this guy
order of a constant
so what that means is that we can
take delta to be order of
lambda times square root of p over n
okay and this implies that in well let
me not rewrite this so this implies that
the min max risk
is omega of so then this uh this delta
gets plugged into delta squared and i
get lambda squared p over n and that's
what we wanted
okay
last example and i think i do actually
have enough time for all of this
so
so what did we learn actually maybe we
should say something about this well
what did we learn is that
in this case um
as i said we
we constructed a set so that all of the
pair-by-scale divergences were bounded
and therefore we just had to calculate
the size of a two-delta separated set
and although it was somewhat complicated
um we were able to go through a volume
argument um and
uh
right glitch which leads to the final
result
okay so let's see one more example
so this one is
high dimensional regression oh i should
give a source for this um
so as i said most of the examples from
most of the content from this lecture
comes from wayne wright's book but for
this particular example that i just did
on covariance estimation
um the
paper is by doming ma and ihong wu
from 2015
and it's called
volume ratio
uh what is it volume ratio
sparsity and minimaxity
under
unitarily invariant norms
okay
and as i said i'm all the examples that
are in this lecture are going to show up
later and in the next lecture i'll be
using this lower bound for covariance
estimation which is why i wanted to
derive it here
all right so um next example last
example is high dimensional regression
and this is something we'll see in the
fourth lecture when we start putting
computation constraints
so
consider
the linear model
y equals x theta plus w
where w is
iid noise zero sigma squared i
and x is fixed
okay and the goal is to estimate
theta which is an rp
where
the true theta
is k sparse
so maybe let me just say so
um
well we're looking at a case where
so y here is uh represents a vector
um x is a matrix
and theta is
the unknown parameter vector
um and then we have another vector and m
n dimensional w so you can think about w
maybe i'll you know this subscript i n
um this is iid noise um
and
and here we're assuming we have a fixed
design so here we assume that x is fixed
so the only randomness comes from these
draws of w and we'll be interested in a
high dimensional case so the
dimensionality of
of n of of x is n by p you can think
about these as the um as the iid
observations
this is like x1 transpose up to
xn transpose
um
and
right and and we want to to recover uh
theta after we observe y and x so in
this case so we're thinking what p is
being much larger than n
okay so
our parameter space
is going to be
the
sparse ball okay so really this means um
all
vectors
in r to the p
with less than or equal to k non-zero
coordinates
okay
so we will show that
in femum over theta hat
supremum over theta and
theta
of
one over n
times expectation
of
x oh i forgot to say one more thing so i
will use my little lasso tool haha
that's ironic um all right so we're
going to look at this guy and we're
gonna show that this is
uh
kappa l squared over kappa u squared
times sigma squared k
log okay i get to use my lasso tool
twice
you can see i don't use live head very
often huh
i'm gonna move this guy down here um so
we'll show that
this is true
and i forgot to tell you
[Music]
what kappa l and kappa u are
so
one more constraint so
we will assume
that x satisfies
kappa l
of theta two norm is bounded by one over
root n
x theta two norm is bounded by kappa u
theta two norm
for all
sparse vectors
okay so this is a sparse eigenvalue
condition
okay so um just to reiterate our
parameter space of theta is just the
case bars vectors
but we have a fixed design x and we
assume that our fixed design matrix has
these upper and lower eigenvalues that
are bounded
and
we are going to to show this lower bound
on the
on what's called the
mean squared prediction risk
mean squared
prediction risk so you might ask why am
i not looking at just theta hat minus
theta and you could look at theta hat
minus theta in fact if you have these
nice conditioning bounds on
um on on the matrix x then you can very
easily change this guy to theta hat
minus theta
the reason why i'm going to write it in
this way is that
as i sort of alluded to i will be
returning to this example in the very
end
in the last lecture where i'm interested
in computational constraints
um and there it will be very important
well there i'm going to start to relax
it's this lower bound condition in
particular on the conditioning of x
okay and and one can only do that in the
case when we're looking at prediction
error rather than theta hat minus theta
alone
okay so um oh yeah one other thing to
note is that theta hat here is usually a
function of x alone but this is a
function now of x and y
well x is fixed y is the guy who's who's
random
okay so we will use
thanos method
with
l of uv
is equal to
oops this should be rho
rho of uv
is equal to 1 over root n times
x
u minus v 2 norm
and
v of t is equal to t squared okay so
here's where i'm going to invoke
a result
so
using
results from coding theory
there exists a subset
script v
which is a subset of
negative 1 0 plus 1
intercept
b sub 0 of k which is a subset of
theta
such that
the size of this guy is at least
p minus k over k to the k over two
and the hamming distance between any two
vectors is at least k over two
for v not equal to v prime okay so what
i'm going to do is i need to create this
two delta separated set right and just
as in the mean estimation case i can
create some arbitrary
set and then rescale it by a factor that
involves delta to make it two delta
separated
so this result from coding theory says
that if i just use um binary values or
really a ternary negative one zero and
one and i'm only allowed to have sparse
codes that have k values um then i can
find a well separated uh subset of codes
and this sort of result comes from
from coding theory from error correcting
codes when you want the codes to be far
enough away and having distance so that
having some errors will still allow you
to tell what the original code was
um so in particular
for v not equal to v prime i have v
minus v prime and two norm is going to
be at least um square root of k over two
all right and this comes from the fact
that all the values are negative one
zero or one so if the hamming distance
at least k over two then every component
is at least well i have
at least k over two components which are
different by at least one each
okay so now we rescale
we take
theta v equals to two delta over
kappa l times square root of 2 over
delta times v
then we can check that we have a two
separated set two delta separated sets
so we have we have to look at our row
metric which was x times theta v
minus x times theta v prime
okay so our conditioning assumption
implies that this is bound lower bounded
by kappa l
times
um
theta hat
theta v minus theta v prime
and this is in turn lower bounded by
kappa l times well i have my rescaling 2
delta over
kappa l times root 2 over delta
i don't know why there's a bracket here
let's get rid of that
and then the separation
here was square root of k over 2. okay
so that comes from this guy goes over
there
okay so if i
chose everything correctly oops sorry
that's not a
uh sorry yes there's a misprint here
this should be a k
so they want this k to go away um and
all together this is two delta good so
everything is two delta separated
um
and then the other thing i need to do is
check that there's an upper bound on the
pairwise kl distances
so also also the pairwise kl distances
are equal to one half one over two sigma
squared
x theta v minus
x
theta v prime
two norm squared so this equality comes
from the fact that i have
i have normal distributions remember
y is the only random thing and we're
conditioning on the value of in this
case
x
theta v and x theta v prime so you can
use the formula for kl divergence
between gaussians that i gave earlier in
the lecture
um and this is in turn bounded by well i
can get rid of the x's using my
conditioning
assumptions so i have
n
kappa u squared
over
2 delta squared times
theta v minus theta v prime 2 norm
squared and
i believe you can check that
this is
8
delta squared over
kappa l squared k times 2k
why is that
um
well
let's assume that i did everything
correctly but at some level there's a
the square of this guy is in here um and
then i think this comes from the fact
that everything is case bars uh yeah so
this is just the square of this guy
right here and then everything is is k
sparse so so the there are most 2k
places in which they separate
um
okay and uh so this is my upper bound on
pairwise kl divergences so then
thanos inequality
gives the lower bound
okay so i have my delta
i square it because
phi was the squared function
i have one minus my upper bound on the
kl divergences
which here should be
8 times
n
delta squared
over
sigma squared
times kappa u squared
over
kappa l squared plus one
and then the size of the set here was
um
there's the size of the set
right the size of the set is this so the
log of that is order of
um
k over 2 times log base 2 of
p minus k over k
and now i again play this game or i want
to bound this by one half
and one can check that
the right choice of delta should be that
delta is order of
kappa delta squared is order of kappa l
squared over kappa u squared times sigma
squared
k
log of
p minus k over k
over n
okay
and um
and this is the rate that we had up
above and the bound is achievable using
the lasso estimator
and let me not state it right now
because we're going to state it again in
the fourth lecture
okay so i think i'll stop there um i one
last thing that i'll mention is that
i think as advertised in the abstract of
this talk i said i would talk about
fano's method and two other methods the
cams method
and
aswad's lemma
i decided not to talk about these and
just to focus on fano throughout this
tutorial
but there's a nice paper by you from
binyu from 1997.
that's called
i don't remember what order it is but
let's say lakam assad and
that's worth a read
it gives examples of when you might use
the other bonds to improve
the other the other dilemmas to prove
lower bounds as well
okay so i'm happy to take some questions
and then maybe go into the break
okay thanks so very much
and um any questions from audience
oh just just a clarification question if
targeting condition that's by itself is
not an implication of uh
sparsity if there is a randomness in the
design of x
i'm sorry what were you asking what the
randomness of the design index so the
restricted eigenvalue condition you
state it as an assumption but isn't it
also an implication under the randomness
of x yes yes that's true okay so so in
this case um for these bounds we're
assuming that x satisfies
these bounds but um this will hold with
high probability if you generate um the
the rows of x i id from some let's say
subgaussian distribution that's well
conditioned but yeah i just want to
double check that thanks yeah
more questions
i'm pulling this design very nice
tutorial so i have a question so if
the qr the kr divergence between two
distributions
happens to be infinity and do you have
any other
say
measure matrix other than the
characteristics to replace
um
[Music]
yes i think um so
uh well i don't know of examples off the
top of my head but i do know that for
the cams method for instance it's in
total variation distance
um so that could be a possibility for a
case in which you might use um the comms
method instead
let's see
so one example i can think of is that if
these two distributions have separate
supports then the characteristics will
be just infinity
right yeah so in that case you would not
want to use these phantoms methods yeah
so yeah thank you
anyone more questions
actually this is a question like in
response to the previous question if you
actually have two distributions with
disjoint supports like this is the law
of your data doesn't that mean you can
perfectly distinguish the two parameters
from the data
oh um yeah i guess that would be true
at least for for unreal specific
question
it's fine
there is one point which makes it
infinitely better but it's a small
probability yeah that's
right then you can still just uh tv
distance yeah is actually the first
effect
and you're first thing okay out there
what is that the relaxation of the tv
these are actually some art form of
archive of the tv distance yeah and so
you scale fails then you go to go back
to the first episode and see where the
tv works
right but mutual information i mean if
you're going to use spano's method then
you want to bound on the mutual
information which i think would already
be infinity
but yeah i mean like all of these come
from um hypothesis testing problems so
you could use tv distance instead of
chaotic divergence in order to um to
characterize the probability of error
which i guess is what happens in the
case of using the comms method instead
okay great so i guess uh let's uh wrap
the questions for now and then um
going if it's okay with you maybe we'll
take a 20 minute break instead of
advertising 15 minute break just to give
people a little bit more time to digest
the first time okay sure okay okay so
let's uh let's wrap up and then we'll be
back in 20 minutes
11.
thanks so much